[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal du mercredi 20 mars sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
jusqu'à dimanche l'industrie se dévoile
neuvième édition de cette semaine pour
découvrir les métiers rencontrer les
professionnels du secteur le coup
d'envoi de cet événement a été donné par
la secrétaire d'état a nié ce panier une
hache et sur le site d'airbus à
elancourt
la france aime le coworking la première
journée nationale de ces espaces de
travail partagés se déroule demain des
lieux pour les micro entreprises les
indépendants ou encore les
télétravailleurs
à cette occasion le 50 koorkin gamme et
réouvrira ses portes aux curieux nous en
parlons avec sa fondatrice blandine
qu'un et les français en consomment
chaque année plus de 25 kg le fromage
est un patrimoine qui se décline par
région dans les yvelines plusieurs
producteurs et même un festival du
fromage qui se tient en octobre
découverte à la fin de ce journal et
nous présenterons également tout à
l'heure la troisième édition de
l'estacade rhône reis une course de
drones ce samedi à l'école d'ingénieurs
l'école de l'estaca à montigny le
bretonneux cette information avant de
développer ces titres une enquête
judiciaire ouverte par le parquet de
versailles pour des soupçons de viol et
détention d'imagés pédopornographiques
elle vise l'ancien maire de fabry heures
roberval aux élus entre 2001 et 2014 il
est suspecté d'avoir abusé sexuellement
de plusieurs jeunes garçons l'homme de
80 ans a été interpellé par la
gendarmerie à des yvelines la semaine
dernière après trois plaintes pour viol
des faits qui se seraient déroulés entre
1995 et 2002 ait d'autres agressions
auraient été dénombrés mais les faits
sont prescrits un juge d'instruction
vient d'être nommé pour mener l enquête
est depuis lundi c'est la neuvième
édition de la semaine de l'industrie
l'objectif c'est de donner un coup de
projecteur sur cette filière est aussi
de découvrir les opportunités
professionnelles auprès des collégiens
et lycéens notamment pour son coup
d'envoi la secrétaire d'état anya
spaniard une hache et s'est rendu sur le
site d'airbus à elancourt patrick
jacques de dixmude et aurélien des
lycéens de saint quentin en yvelines
venu en apprendre plus sur l'entreprise
airbus dit
in space sur ce site implanté à ils
encourent des ingénieurs travaillent
notamment sur la cybersécurité ou encore
l'électronique de défense
on a une nouvelle révolution
industrielle qui est devant nous qui est
l'utilisation de logiciels l'utilisation
du big data l'utilisation d'une machine
learning de l'indigence un ciel tout ça
dans de la production qu'on pourrait
imaginer pourtant classique et ça c'est
l'usiné du futur une industrie qui se
renouvelle et qui offre de nombreuses
opportunités d'emploi selon la
secrétaire d'état ni espagne et une
hache et 50000 emplois ne seraient pas
pourvus dans ce secteur les français ne
savent pas exactement ce qu'est leur
industrie on imagine beaucoup comme
germinal des métiers pénibles des
métiers qui paye mal des métiers qui
vont disparaître alors que c'est tout le
contraire
ce sont des métiers qui paye 20 % de
plus que l'ensemble des autres secteurs
ce sont des métiers qui sont durables ce
sont des métiers qui ont du sens les
visiteurs d'un jour ont pu découvrir les
ateliers ainsi que les équipements
électroniques spatiaux même si toutes et
tous ne se destine pas forcément à une
carrière dans cette entreprise
ils ont été impressionnés pour moi
c'était une entreprise même pas avec une
telle ampleur et beaucoup de monde comme
ça notre message aujourd'hui était de
leur faire comprendre que c'était ouvert
à tous que ce n'est pas forcément que
des ingénieurs qui vient de travailler
chez nous et qu'il ya de la place pour
tous les jeunes
et que les métiers scientifiques ne sont
pas si compliqué que ça la semaine de
l'industrie se poursuit jusqu'au 24 mars
avec l'ambition de susciter de nouvelles
vocations et des chiffres publiés chaque
année le ministère de l'éducation
nationale a dévoilé ses indicateurs de
résultats des lycées plusieurs médias
établissent à partir de ces données leur
propre classement nouveau partageons le
plus local celui de nos confrères du
parisien c'est le lycée privé des
châtaigniers à versailles qui décroche
la première place de ce palmarès 2010 9
devant le lycée international de saint
germain en laye celui des mureaux
françois villon qui intègre le top 10
les châtaigniers établissement
professionnel et technologique se voit
récompensé de son accompagnement poussée
des élèves l accompagnement un critère
important du classement du parisien qui
prend en compte également le taux de
réussite au baccalauréat et le taux de
mentions et mais aussi la capacité à
faire progresser les élèves dans les dix
premières places on note la présence de
cet établissement public dont jean vilar
à plaisir 5e encore le lycée militaire
de saint cyr l'école
trois lycées sont eux basé à versailles
lui était justement à la rencontre des
lycéens leur députée johanne jean marie
et à cavada a tenu une conférence au
lycée marie-curie de versailles mardi
150 élèves de terminale y ont assisté
ancien journaliste devenu homme
politique il a parlé de son rôle et de
l'union européenne à quelques mois du
scrutin pour élire les parlementaires de
bruxelles et strasbourg lé détail de
nicolas landry ne demandez pas ce que
votre pays peut faire pour vous demandez
vous ce que vous pouvez faire pour votre
pays
une célèbre phrase du président
américain john fitzgerald kennedy pour
sa conférence face à des lycéens
l'eurodéputé jean marie cavada voulu
transmettre cet état d'esprit s'engager
pour la société si l'on veut que les
choses aillent mieux
il faut se lever de son fauteuil il faut
faire quelque chose pour le collectif
est leur première étape s'est
naturellement femmes et les élections
européennes parce que beaucoup des lois
auxquelles vous obéissez les uns et les
autres
plus de la moitié viennent de bruxelles
alors il faut se rebeller pour son
intervention au lycée marie-curie
l'union européenne étaient au coeur des
échanges ses valeurs son fonctionnement
mais aussi des améliorations à apporter
face à des lycéens ayant leur regard sur
la question je pense que c'est important
au final construit ni autour d'une union
parce que ça rassemble les gens
et forcément face à la montée en
puissance de la chine par exemple
aujourd'hui et la puissance américaine
finalement on est tous dans le même dans
le même bateau on est tous en europe etc
et c'est important qu'on soit tous unis
en france on n'est pas non plus un pays
très grand donc en soi même si les
français font des efforts ce qui est
très important
ça ne suffira pas à sauver notre planète
malheureusement donc il faut qu'on soit
sur un échelle qu'ils soient plus grande
nos élèves sont déjà citoyen parce
qu'ils votent ou de futurs citoyens
il est hyper important qu'en dehors de
toute part tidianisme et prises de
position et un éclairage sur les enjeux
de notre société surtout en ce moment
pour pouvoir prendre des positions saine
sereine et éclairé jean marie cavada
devrait terminer son troisième mandat
sans le renouveler d'après sa promesse
initiale
sauf si une urgence absolue le pousse à
se représenter
on vous parlait tout à l'heure de la
semaine de l'industrie autre événement
c'est demain c'est la première journée
nationale du coworking la france aime le
coworking pour promouvoir ces espaces de
travail partagés
plus de mille en france associé à
l'événement dont le vôtre blandine
pierre bonsoir on pense à vous est la
fondatrice et l'animatrice du 50 un
espace de coworking qui a ouvert à la
mairie il ya 3 ans et demi on va
présenter le programme demain de cet
événement lors le coworking c'est donc
un espace de travail partagé
à qui s'adresse ce type de lieu est ce
que c'est ce que ces larges finalement
alors effectivement quand working c'est
un espace de travail et c'est aussi
fondamentalement une communauté de
travail du décès de créer du lien entre
les gens doux
la condition impérative d'avoir
quelqu'un qui soit là pour l'animer et
pour le faire vivre au quotidien
donc de ce fait la cible de ces espaces
extrêmement large puisqu'on a on va dire
un coeur de cible que sont les
freelances les indépendants des gens qui
sont mis à leur compte et qui au départ
travail plus tôt de chez eux qu'ils se
sentent un peu isolé qui finissent par
arriver un petit peu au bout de leur
réseau professionnel et qui viennent
dans des espaces de coworking pour
retrouver le lien qu'ils auraient pu
avoir avec des collègues avec les
avantages du collègue à savoir la
convivialité sans les inconvénients que
serait une relation hiérarchique un peu
pesante ou des horaires à respecter
voilà l'objet si on doit cibler les
avantages justement c'est ce lien qui
peut se créer entre les différents corps
coeur si ce lien qui se crée de façon
quasi systématique entre les corps coeur
puisque pour vous donner un exemple ceux
qui prennent un bureau fermé parce que
c'est pas que l'open space
le coworking il commence par fermer la
porte de leur bureau et puis très vite
la porte reste ouverte et puis très vite
ils se mettent aussi à travailler dans
les autres espaces du lieu donc il ya
vraiment des usages qui s'invente
quotidien et puis au delà de ces
freeland c2c indépendant on voit de plus
en plus des barques et des tpe des start
up
ils installent leur équipe dans ces
lieux là parce que c'est un cadre qui
est stimulant et qui leur permet aussi
de trouver des ressources des
compétences sur place et on a aussi des
grandes entreprises qui commencent à
s'intéresser au sujet puisque pour eux
c'est une façon aussi de réduire les
transports les trajets pour leurs
collaborateurs sans pour autant tous les
laisser à domicile est ce que les
patrons sont intégrés ça ou pas assez
encore justement peut-être
proposer au salarié de pouvoir faire du
télétravail au sein des espaces de
coworking une à deux journées par
semaine plusieurs plusieurs journées par
semaine et ce qu'ils l'ont intégré ça
les patrons aujourd'hui on en est en
plus tôt à la phase d'expérimentation où
quelques grandes entreprises et
collectivités sont emparés du sujet et
ont testé ça ce qu'on était vraiment au
bout de la démarche avec des systèmes
d'accompagnement de réajustement la
plupart ont été convaincus et ont
déployé le dispositif
il y en a encore beaucoup d'autres
combats osé franchir le pas et c'est
bien pour ça qu'on organise la journée
nationale du coworking demain pour
amener ces grandes entreprises et ses
collectivités à franchir les portes des
espaces qu'ils seront tous les espaces
partenaires propose une journée portes
ouvertes demain aux 50 ce sera de 14
heures à 19 heures et c'est l'occasion
de venir voir en vrai en faisant tomber
un certain nombre de préjugés qu'on
pourra avoir sur ces espaces découvrir
comment ça fonctionne
quels sont les usages possibles parce
que au-delà d'un espace ouvert comme je
vous le disais il ya des espaces fermés
qui permettent aussi non plus 50 il ya
plusieurs espaces proposés alors il ya
deux open space
un calme un rouge qui permet de
continuer à téléphoner à interagir dans
cet espace là il ya des bureaux fermés
qui sont attitrés à temps plein et puis
on a aussi des bureaux de passage qui
permettent de se mettre à l'écart pour
un rendez vous téléphonique confidentiel
pour des rendez-vous physique qu'on
pourra avoir des réunions et on a tout
un espace meeting qui permet aussi
d'accueillir des formations et des
séminaires d'entreprises qui voudraient
apprendre un petit peu de recul par
rapport à leur quotidien et qui viennent
se mettre au vert chez nous pourrions
plus en journée les plusieurs formules
on peut y venir à la journée au moins
voilà il ya plusieurs formules juste
pour clôturer cet entretien sur le
programme de demain la journée qui
commencera à 14h qu'est ce qui est prévu
pour cette journée naturel du coworking
américo tout l'après midi on sera en
mode portes ouvertes donc n'importe qui
même sans inscription peut venir frapper
à la porte du 50 demain
l'idée c'est de pouvoir visiter les
lieux mais aussi s'ils le souhaitent
s'installer pour travailler quelques
heures est vraiment expérimenté par soi
même le coworking
et puis de 17 à 19 heures il y aura une
retransmission d'un plateau télé qui va
être organisée au niveau national et qui
comprendra deux grandes étapes un
premier débat sur les bénéfices du
coworking expliquer en quoi c'est
intéressant pour l'entreprise elle-même
et pas que pour ses salariés de deux de
switcher vers ce mode d'organisation et
puis le deuxième qui tournera autour des
tiers lieux du lien entre tient lieu et
collectivités locales et savoir dans
quelle mesure on peut s'apporter
mutuellement des choses aussi on
retrouve toutes les informations soient
sur le site du 50 ou sur le site
également nationale pour cette journée
nationale du comores king merci blandine
haquin d'être passé sur ce plateau en
france a de l'espace du 52,50 coworking
qui est située à merris la 98e édition
de la foire de chatou est programmé
jusqu'à dimanche à l'île des
impressionnistes l'occasion de découvrir
sur place plus de 55 cents exposants
amical et demi d'euros et patrick jacq
de dix minutes se sont rendus sur place
c'est la plus grande brocante de france
la 90e rang d'international de chatou
est installé depuis le 15 mars sur l'île
des impressionnistes
chaque année près de 30000 curieuse
déambule dans ses allées c'est une foire
qui permet aux visiteurs de chine et les
objets de 1 euro ax
on peut y trouver aussi liens de petits
objets que des antiquités digne de
musées
parmi les 500 exposants présents benoît
moreau fête cette année sa huitième
participation à cette foire se
passionnés de brocante restaure des
meubles anciens
on a beaucoup de meubles comme ça c'est
les meubles que l'on trouvait dans les
administrations milieu du xxème siècle
que l'on aime transformer complètement
pour les réadapter que qu'on puisse les
utiliser dans un intérieur beaucoup plus
contemporain voilà les rendre un peu
plus sexy un peu plus attractif et on
les modifie pour après leur donner une
vraie utilité si vous êtes plutôt bijoux
anciens la spécialiste claudette ce
picard propose depuis 20 ans sa
sélection sur la foire la brocanteuse
coche ce rendez-vous dans son agenda
plusieurs mois al avance à la une
ambiance qu'on trouve nulle part
ailleurs
c'est festif c'est convivial tout le
monde
tout le monde est heureux de participer
je pense à cette foire et les clients
sont ravis de venir passer une journée
quand il fait beau
enfin même quand il pleut pour découvrir
ces trésors sous le soleil ou sous la
pluie vous avez jusqu'à ce dimanche 24
mars la perle rare se trouve peut-être
au détour d'une allée avant d'accueillir
mon deuxième invité marylène yapi chine
au mas a rejoint un plateau bonsoir
alors pour la rubrique patrimoine
également consommation vous allez nous
parler d'une spécialité culinaire bien
connue des français c'est le fromage
chaque français consomme plus de 25
kilos de fromage par an marylène alors
tout à fait nous sommes le deuxième pays
le plus courant en fromage derrière la
grèce il faut dire que c'est un
savoir-faire bien français et dans les
yvelines
on n'est pas en reste connaissez-vous le
bleu de chèvre cendré et le sens jacques
grégory non pas du tout alors ils
viennent du sud des yvelines du village
de la boissière école la ferme de la
tramblais contient 150 vaches et 350 ch
oeuvre qui passe à la traite deux fois
par jour et dont le lait par directement
dans la fromagerie interne à la ferme
au total ce sont 40 mille fromages qui
sont produits par an d'une dizaine de
variétés différentes
parmi elles le saint-jacques fabriqué
ici depuis 50 ans et sa déclinaison à la
sauge mais aussi le fameux bleu de
chèvre cendré primé en 2018 au concours
national agricole pour l'anecdote
grégory je n'ai pas pu rentrer dans la
fromagerie le secret du bleu de chèvre
est bien gardé je vous laisse écouter
olivier veillée responsable commercial
de la ferme de la tramblais là c'est le
persillé le persil et de chèvre cendré
donc c'est une fromagerie fait un kilo
qui est qui et très doux assez crémeux
est assez facile d'accès pour tous les
amateurs de fromage
même ceux qui n'aiment pas ni le bleu ni
la chair parce que justement il est très
doux en bleu l'heure du repas approche
ça peut être alléchant ce fromage on
peut le retrouver ou non il vous fait
envie rigoler on retrouve ses promenades
dans les commerces de proximité et chez
les professionnels car la firme de la
tramblais travaille avec des grossistes
ils font même de l'exportation aux états
unis en nouvelle zélande et en australie
mais pas besoin de traverser le globe
pour en goûter je me suis rendu dans la
boutique tout un fromage rambouillet la
fromagerie de ludovic biseau en fromage
et meilleur ouvrier de france et membre
de la ligue des fromages et
extraordinaire se sont tous passionnés
qui veulent révéler les pouvoirs
magiques du fromage j'ai retrouvé notre
fromage yvelinois mais aussi toutes
sortes de variétés et même des fromages
qui avait disparu j'aime bien faire
découvrir ce petit fromage de bourgogne
qui s'appelle le fermier au chablis
fromage de lait de vache l'aveo chablis
qui est un fromage que j'ai fait
renaître que j'ai ouï j'ai relancé avec
un camarade qui est fromager en
bourgogne dans l'yonne et on c'est un
fromage que se consommer dans mon
enfance qui avait disparu et j'ai voulu
le voir renaître et donc maintenant il
est imé sortie on l'a mis au point il
est sorti l'année dernière et j'aime
beaucoup le faire découvrir et il a
beaucoup de succès alors il m'a confié
que ce qu'ils vendaient le plus c'était
surtout le duo star camembert bri les
franciliens prennent les habitudes de
leurs voisins normands ainsi que le
comté 18 mois d'affinage unique trop
doux ni trop fort ça veut dire c'est à
dire marylène à vous écouter les
yvelines sont en fait une terre de
fromage alors savez vous qu'il existe
même un festival des fromages d'un
département
il a lieu à meulan en yvelines depuis
plus de vingt ans le deuxième week-end
du mois d'octobre
plus de 300 variétés ils sont
représentés et il attire plus de 30000
visiteurs après le sud-ouest l'année
dernière c'est la bretagne qui mettra à
l'honneur en 2019
une cinquantaine de fromages et et une
vingtaine de vignerons seront présents
puis si vous voulez connaître les
secrets de fabrication du fromage
la ferme pédagogique de l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines propose des
ateliers de la mamelle à la gamelle les
dimanches matin à 10 heures alors ne
vous précipitez pas trop les chèvres ne
sont pas encore prêtes elles viennent
tout juste de mettre bas il faut
attendre le sevrage de leurs petits des
ateliers devraient reprendre en vacances
de pâques
merci marlène pour nous avoir donné faim
dans ce journal merci pour toutes ces
informations
il yad'autres une autre personne qui m'a
rejoint en plateau c'est benoît lydon
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
de l'estac à modélisme alors site une
association d'étudiants de l'estac à
l'estaca c'est bien sûr l'école
d'ingénieurs basée à montigny le
bretonneux et vous organisé ce samedi la
troisième édition de l'estacade redresse
de 9 heures à 18 heures c'est une course
de drones qui va se dérouler dans le
parking souterrain de l'estaca alors si
une troisième édition c'est à dire que
c'est un événement qui commence à
s'installer à l'estaca c'est important
pour vous de l'organiser chaque année
oui exactement alors nous sommes
actuellement en train d'organiser la
troisième édition après deux premières
éditions organisées par les bureaux
précédent c'est une édition qui se tient
dans la lignée des précédentes
c'est-à-dire que nous
continuons de développer à la fois le
circuit mais aussi la communication
autour
lors des premières éditions nous ne
possédions pas le matériel qui nous
permettait d' illuminé le parking
puisque le parking est plongé dans le
noir et nos balises ont le circuit à
l'aide de l'aide mais petit à petit nous
concevons et nous construisons notre
propre circuit pour lui donner vraiment
toute son originalité et permet de
développer l'événement pour démocratiser
à la fois la course de drones et
permettent de développer tout ce qu'ils
aient accès au public
donc c'est un événement qui progresse
d'année en année c'est organisé par
votre association l'estaca modélisme
qu'est ce que vous y faites dans cette
association donc l'estaca modélisme
c'est une des associations de l'estaca
c'est celle qui est référente en termes
de modélisme sur le campus de saint
quentin en yvelines nous officiant
principalement dans les domaines des
transports donc le ferroviaire
l'automobile mais plus principalement
dans l'aéronautique au sein de
l'association nous avons plusieurs types
de projets donc tout d'abord les projets
techniques qui regroupe 2 2 à une
dizaine de membres en règle générale
ceux là ont tendance à répondre à des
cahiers des charges qui sont fixés lors
de concours auquel nous participons ou
lors de cahier des charges que nous
fixons nous mêmes afin d'avoir des
performances technologiques nouvelles et
de développer de nouvelles solutions à
certains projets mais précise juste que
c'est directement en lien avec l'estac a
puisque l'estac a est une école
d'ingénieurs spécialisés dans le domaine
des mobilités alors pourquoi organiser
un événement autour du drone excuses
c'est une pratique qui se développe de
plus en plus adeptes des drones alors
exactement depuis quelques années le
drone crois vraiment de plus en plus de
place dans la vie de tous les jours on
l'a pu le voir dans la capacité des
personnes à acheter des drones dans les
magasins de grande distribution
c'est un appareil qui a vraiment besoin
de peu de place pour évoluer par rapport
aux avions puisqu'il est très très
simple à piloter en règle générale donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui tend à
se développer en termes de modélisme et
puis les composants sont de plus en plus
accessible ce qui permet vraiment aux
personnes ayant des petits moyens de
pouvoir acheter aussi un drone est là
pour cette course donc c'est des drogues
qui seront pilotés avec une lunette de
réalité virtuelle c'est des drones
parfaitement adaptés à la course et des
drones spécialisés pour pour la course
oui le drone de course n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec le drone grand public
il à part le fait d'être un multi coop
terre ces drones là sont vraiment conçu
pour la course en tête en termes de
performances il n'est pas rare d'avoir
des drones qui font le 0 à 100 20 km en
3 secondes
ceux du grand public ne peuvent pas
dépasser les 70 km/heure en règle
générale donc ce sont vraiment des
drones qui sont conçus et réalisés par
les pilotes est propre à la course
non justement ses pilotes le profil de
ces participants est ce qu'ils viennent
de partout en france et ce qu'ils
viennent aussi de l'étranger alors dans
les éditions précédentes nous avions
uniquement des pilotes français mais
grâce à certains pilotes lors de
l'édition précédente qui avait vraiment
de grands contact sur le circuit
international nous commençons à attirer
des pilotes qui viennent entre autres
par exemple de belgique d'accord donc ça
veut dire que ça évolue des pilotes de
belgique sur le profil en tout cas sur
le niveau est ce que c'est
des spécialistes du de la course et ce
qu'ils en feront plusieurs parents et ce
qu'ils ont des titres en la matière
alors la plupart des drones des pilotes
de drones pardon sont vraiment des
professionnels du domaine
il s'entraîne vraiment toute l'année et
donc ce sont vraiment des personnes qui
ont ça comme passe temps mais aussi
comme sport un petit peu comme des
pilotes de formule 1 au final donc
actuellement nous avons vraiment des
pilotes professionnels et dont c'est le
métier
alors vous l'avez dit vous allez plonger
le parking souterrain dans le noir avec
des guirlandes lumineuses pour pour le
circuit justement ce circuit comment
l'avez vous préparez quelles sont ses
particularités ses difficultés à ce
circuit alors on le fait évoluer d'année
en année mais la constante et le fait
que ce soit un parking souterrain qui
soient plongées dans le noir comme vous
l'aviez dit et ensuite une balise on
avec des leds
nous concevons tous les ans différents
modules qui nous permettent d'avoir une
certaine originalité d'une édition sur
l'autre et ensuite en fonction des
retours des pilotes ont fait plutôt
évoluer certaines choses tout en gardant
ce qui avait plutôt bien marché donc il
faut juste préciser que les inscriptions
sont encore ouvertes pour les
participants ceci jusqu'à demain soir
jeudi vous pouvez le faire sur le lien
qui s'affiche actuellement en bas
d'écran on pourra aussi assister à la
compétition être dans le public aussi
bien aux abords du circuit mais il ya
également une retransmission sur écran
géant qui est prévu oui exactement donc
le circuit sera accessible dans une zone
sécurisée que nous aménagerons donc où
les personnes pourront assister en
direct à la course sur place et
parallèlement à ça dans l'auditorium de
l'estaca sera diffusé en live commenté
grâce à notre société de chronométrage
et donc les personnes pour assister dans
cette salle au live et il ya aussi tout
un programme d'animations qui
seront proposés qui sera proposé pour
cette journée où exactement en fait la
course est vraiment le coeur de
l'activité de la journée mais
parallèlement à ça on va faire
différentes activités d'initiation à la
fois au pilotage de drones que ce soit
sur des drones réel mais aussi sur
simulateur donc informatique et à côté
de ça on fera aussi des initiations et
différents outils de conception propre à
l'ingénieur qui nous servent tous les
jours pour développer les pièces au sein
de l'association donc une grande journée
autour du drone et je rappelle que
l'estacade redresse débutera à 9 heures
ce samedi rendez vous sur le campus de
l'istac à saint quentin en yvelines à à
montigny le bretonneux merci ben ali
dont d'être passé sur ce plateau
président de l'association de l'estaca
modélisme aller avant de se quitter
notre petit tour habituel dans les
salles obscures saint-quentinoise
direction le signer cette d'elancourt la
programmation et du cinéma au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude cette semaine
au ciné c'est du 20 au 26 mars plein de
belles choses à voir d'excellents films
de très bons films
je vais commencer par les excellents que
je vais citer rapidement qui est con à
la fiche depuis un certain temps mais
qu'il faut absolument voir grâce à dieu
de françois ozon évidemment la favorite
l'excellent film du réalisateur grèce
yorgos lanthimos le mystère épique et
green book qui a eu comme vous savez un
oscar à hollywood et aussi cette semaine
de très bonnes comédies à la fiche
la première c'est bon bébé de lisa
azuelos avec sandrine kiberlain qui
raconte un peu les affres pour une maman
du départ en fait de l'enfant de l'aîné
de la maison c'est pas toujours facile
donc le film en parle avec finesse et
tendresse et le second sur tous ces
rebelles qui est un film d'alain mauduit
avec un trio assez somptueux cécile de
france
audrey lamy quelle excellente yolande
moreau
les deux autres étant c'est donc aussi
alors c'est quoi cette histoire c'est
l'histoire de trois ouvrières dans une
usine de fabrication de boîtes de
conserves de poissons qui vont se
rebeller un petit peu contre leur chef
on trouve qu'elles subissent au
quotidien alors c'est assez trash mais
il faut le voir c'est du tarantino à la
française on va dire donc attendez vous
à quelque chose qui déménage qu'ils ont
eu
et donc c'est à voir dans nos salles
cette semaine aussi dès cette journée a
disparu avec le pognon des belges
pourquoi tu leur a pas dit pourquoi tu
te rases écoute avec ma ces
quelques images pour se quitter en ce
jour du printemps le carnaval le
carnaval organisé par les étudiants de
médecine de l'uvm q vous le voyez sur
ces images qui sont allés à la rencontre
des étudiants d'autres filières sur le
campus de guyancourt ça c'était cet
après midi c'est la fin du set 8 journal
le replay sur notre site internet et
votre application mobile place aux 7,8
débat dans quelques minutes or ils iront
reviendra avec ses invités sur la fuite
d'hydrocarbures qui a touché les
yvelines quelles conséquences pour le
territoire c'est dans un instant et
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]